i have warned everyone
that we are going to be seeing an
explosion
of radicalization through right-wing
media during these next two years
i've been saying for months now that
trump's insanity is going to be replaced
by right-wing media insanity
and that will include fox news having to
do something wacky
to get an audience back from newsmax and
oan
but it will likely also include newsmax
and oan
going even more extreme now that donald
trump is gone and we haven't had to wait
even a minute to see it
newsmax host chris salcedo i actually
appeared on this guy's old radio show
some years ago
chris salcedo claims that democrats are
pushing us towards civil war let's take
a look and then discuss
in my opinion democrats dangerous
rhetoric their vacuous charges and
feigned fear
are pushing america toward a civil war
the question remains
why many on the republican side have
noted on many occasions that democrats
have disarmed their voters through
irrational fears of
firearms those same republicans
rationalize they would be foolhardy
for democrats to pick a civil war fight
that they would sure assuredly lose
but the democrats wouldn't be alone now
can you folks think of a nation on the
planet earth that would benefit from
be elated by or pushing for an american
civil war i can't that's right
joe biden's buddies china if america is
pushed into a civil war by the democrats
that will benefit the world's most
inhuman racist
slave state china the policy course
sorted by
socialist democrats is counter to
american freedom liberty and prosperity
their rhetoric may threaten our very
existence the republic
itself someone should wake up mitt
romney pat toomey and ben sasse
i know i know you might be saying wait a
second hold on
wasn't it trump and don jr
and rudy giuliani and marjorie taylor
green and lauren beaubert who were
pushing us closer to civil war
by fomenting and inciting an armed
insurrection to try to keep the guy who
lost in power
does this guy chris salcedo not remember
that it was
armed violent republicans that stormed
the capital weeks ago
but chris salcedo says it's democrats
pushing us towards civil war
wasn't it republicans who for two months
hesitated to even admit that joe biden
had won the election
threatening the very basic institutions
of democracy but it's democrats that are
pushing us towards civil war
and democrats that are putting our
country at risk of not being
a democratic country the people who
draped themselves in the confederate
flag which represents literally the
loser in the civil war
stormed the capital to try to overturn
the results of an election
and they are now the ones saying
democrats are pushing
us to civil war how can this be now the
one funny thing
there isn't there isn't much funny about
this but there is one funny part
newsmax guy says democrats are pushing
us to civil war
but they would lose because they don't
have weapons because they're against
guns
newsmax guy seems to think that if there
were
such a civil war it would be republican
citizens
versus democratic citizens just like
random voters
fighting with handguns and rifles in the
streets the reality is that in such a
civil war
that was started by these
insurrectionists most americans would be
staying at home
and it would be the insurrectionists
versus the full power of the us
government and military
so the idea that biden and democrats
would lose is very funny
but i don't even want to focus on that
because it is so
unbelievably absurd but the bottom line
here
is that democrats are not the ones
inciting
a civil war fomenting a civil war
or demanding a civil war newsmax
oan and others that are broadcasting
and promoting disunity and conspiracies
while perpetuating the election fraud
lies
are the ones pushing us closer to civil
war i don't think it will happen for a
variety of different reasons
but if it were to it's not going to be
republican and democratic voters
fighting it out with handguns
and as we've talked about before
geographically that also doesn't make
sense since increasingly you know we
talk about red and blue states
but really what we have are urban areas
and even suburban areas which are uh
heavily and leaning more to the left
in states that may be blue states or red
states with significantly more red
rural counties around them so all of the
language they're using about civil war
is wrong
all of the framing they're using about
civil war is wrong but the idea that
it's democrats fomenting it
doesn't pass the sniff test as you've
heard me say before